шановні друзі гарматне м'ясо указ про
часткової реалізації підписано її
головна мета послабити роз'єднати і
знищити кінцевий результат нашої країни
вона повинна розпастися на безліч
смертельно ворогують між собою
регіонів та областей Росія має бути
всіма засобами розгромлена в
подальшому позбавленням політичного
економічного культурного взагалі
всякого
усіма, хто має
традиції у долі нашого народу політика
залякування
вбивають людей
[музика]
Давай м'ясо Давай м'ясо
ось армія наші чуваки [ __ ]
це кавалерівський військкомат менти
почекай
ліньки тебе знімають
Ось він я на передову їдемо Ось він я
ось ми в такому стані Все їдемо все в
такому стані хлопці їдуть
найдешевші тампони
[музика]
Господи благослови Сполучені Штати
Рашка [ __ ]
[музика]
мобілізація проходить причину
[оплески]
[музика]
У мене друг 15 років мешкає на території
Російської Федерації
і позавчора він нарешті отримав
громадянство Російської Федерації
[сміх]
[оплески]
дуже добре спрацює як для треу
Уявіть у них якісь втрати
величезний втрати А у нас всього лише 3
300 у цьому ранковому вилазці ми там такий
Шурхіт навели
просто знищили вони там просто драпали
Вони кричали спецура працює
з ним спитай що в нього
штучне дихання швидко швидко
буде жити будеш
[сміх]
[музика]
сьогодні дай йому шкідливого місця
з гідності пом'ята традицію кисля
концерту на Приморській площі
збиралася і давала всім хто хоче Рог і
схожою
подівайся
піднімати свої продовження
[музика]
Та йому вірно попливав Раніше я приходи в
дому і казавши свої дружині Я проходжу і
ходжу Давай вип йому ви на і будемо послуг
і дощ
так романтично було зараз я прихожую
говорю Давай вип'ємо ви на і будемо погано
ти поїхала СБУ
дуються такі штучки такі штучки теж
Діма скажи мені
на заводи
і голову собі на плечі і такі на вежу
Мамочка
мамулечка пам'ятаєш
[оплески]
[музика]
Ну, все тепер мені точно
казкові тварюки не будьте як вдома вам
тут офіційно не радіє це факт це мій
будинок тому Будь ласкав Заходь у нього з
добрими намірами або йди на
вчора відбувся черговий обмін полоненими
між Росією та Україною Україна
отримала 215 своїх військових у тому числі
до крайності демонізованих азовців
які захищали Азовсталь у Маріуполі
їхні командири яких Росія обіцяла
ніколи не міняти і розстріляти тепер
також на свободі в Росії вже повернули 55
російських військових і кума Путіна
Віктора медведчука якого російські
влада також раніше обіцяла не міняти на
азовців
[музика]
участь в історичному референдумі
прийняв і самий світлий князь Григорій
Олександрович потьомкін-тавричний
державний діяч творець
Чорноморського військового флоту та його
першою головний генерал
фельдмаршал саме він заснував Катерина
Слав Херсон Севастополь Миколаїв А в
1784 року був генерал-губернатором
новоросії славне місто Мелітополь ми з
матінкою Катериною ці міста заснували
і разом з Росією їм бути винна ми
разом Росія
[музика]
дорогі жителі Російської Федерації
настав час з 23 по 27 вересня ми
проводимо референдум у якому ви можете
голосувати за приєднання Голландії Ну
це звичайно хочете
Перестаньте слухати брехні Путіна
приховує від вас що історична Росія
належить до нідерландів настало
час об'єднатися наш король Вільям 4
теж ваш король
1816 року Анна Павлівна 1 вийшла заміж за
Вільям 2
Ну та він погано говорить російською
і нічого впораємося
[музика]
своїм королем на здоров'я і це ж не
випадково, що Рідна дочка Путіна роками
вже живе
повірте там за кайфом ніхто не живе
тільки за свою справжню батьківщину
Кремль більше від вас приховує у
Горбачова зовсім не було жодної родимки
це було татуювання Голландії Ну і у нас
прапор майже однакові тут просто потрібно
білу частину вниз Ні білу частину між
Ой ні це фермери перевернути так так Ось
бачите Урал названий у частину фестивалю в
Сибір походить від фрискової та
слідчого сип і
додаткова Вигода Якщо ви
приєднайтесь Голландії ваші сини не
помиратимуть у безглуздій війні
проти України Класно Класно
голосувати можете онлайн через мене
хочеться Голландії точка
точно
через лівий берег можна з Польщі коротше
там випускають Господа новий вата такий
вати тонун
[музика]
[оплески]
Ти що мені вказуватимеш на якому
мовою розмовляти
вільна країна Я говорю як хочу що
ти скажеш російськомовним військовим вони
теж воюють Може їх сафронта
яка різниця якою мовою
розмовляю Головне щоб людина була
гарний
Ну могла отримувати та виходить але нічого
отримаєш
[музика]
знаєте люди на сушку програв І все
шахової партії смоли.
що
постійно я Україна блискавки
далай-лама з Білої Церкви
Я не розумію в чому проблема, але
ми знаємо З рашки перед тим як
прокляту щось заблукану
написала мені в Інстаграмі
скажи я дивлюся в цьому все на свій
українську перейшли незабаром взагалі Русский
мову забудете Я такі дякую заїдаю
[оплески]
слово паски
паски
так росіяни називають великодній хліб
ляя початися кисть наріст на тілі
[сміх]
Миколи сьогодні не буде йому паски
видаляють
не з України
Я за України
Молодці хлопці
Ну скажи ще раз яхти обчислюєш росіян
[музика]
я його розумів вона можна на ньому була коти
а ти зможеш
[музика]
в Україні ми покараємо
ми кажемо Та нічого
[музика]
чому б не дзвонили в мережі дні
взагалі в Азії зачистка Вільні вурха
Віллі Як Україна
ми не здалося 4 куриш
крові
[музика]
ні хрону